[Music]
hey y'all what the hell day is it i
don't know tuesday right
yeah i think it's tuesday yeah it's
tuesday because i forgot for a second
yeah that's true tuesday wednesday
my brain is breaking down
last night man [ __ ] i tonya it was
good it was real good i [ __ ] loved
this
it's got that
girl who played
joker's girlfriend and um
birds of prey what was it what's that uh
what's the name of harley quinn yeah she
plays tonya harding in it and margot
robbie that's what they have
and she was in once upon a time in
hollywood yeah she has another good role
that she does she's a great [ __ ]
actress she's great she's really good i
was impressed with her she could uh
i mean just change her hair and her
makeup and just dress like [ __ ]
redneck 90s and it just totally changes
the way she looks she's wearing braces
at certain times and you would never
know that that was
beautiful ass margot rob
kind of just like average girl really
you know even though tanya tanya in real
life she was she was kind of cute she
was cute yeah that was a yeah she was
actually a very a very attractive uh
young lady back in the 90s this is uh i
haven't seen her lately kind of a
comedic
story but true and kind of boy kind of
tragic in a way of [ __ ] what happened
to her ass
it's true crime so kind of i mean
well their crime happens well yeah
they're trying crime happens in it and
it was a scandal man if you lived
through this [ __ ] [ __ ] it was all
over i remember it was all over
everything i remember all of this
happening like in real time she was like
a national pariah for a while yeah and
uh then quickly replaced uh by oj the oj
case yeah and they actually kind of uh
have that happen at the end like right
you know the the press are all leaving
from out in front of jeff goli's house
and then on the tv is the
is the you know bronco chase yeah like
the o.j simpson thing this is a great
movie
yeah we had i had actually been wanting
to see this for a long time i can't
believe it came out it's like 2017.
that's how long ago this came out
and it uh it was nominated for a [ __ ]
ton of oscars uh it actually won
allison janney who played um her mom won
best supporting actress yeah she's great
oscar and she won a golden globe
everybody uh margot robbie was nominated
but she didn't win
um but this got like a whole bunch of uh
of nominations anyway and i think i
didn't see any i don't think i saw any
negative reviews of it i mean i didn't
look at all of them but most of the
reviews were like overwhelmingly
positive it's about a bunch of dumbasses
it's funny
yeah it's it's funny it's it's it's
funny and it's tragic it's it's like
it's like up there with pain and gain if
you like the movie painting game yeah it
was kind of like a similar very similar
because it's a it's a serious topic
there's serious stuff it's a serious
crime and it's bad and there's a lot of
stuff about like domestic abuse and
stuff like that and you would think that
you wouldn't be able to make a dark
comedy out of that and like make but it
really works yeah it's funny but it's
not really making fun of not exactly
it's not it's it's a really difficult
balance to
kind of uh you know do but it really
seems like this movie actually did it
really well growing up in the 90s when
this case happened you weren't really
sure what the [ __ ] was true and what
wasn't because the media would just tell
you anything
uh some well and that's kind of one of
the themes of this movie too because
it's almost some of it is done like re
you know like an actual movie but some
of it's done like mockumentary yeah
where they're like interviewing because
what the director of the movie did
was he actually interviewed
uh the real tanya harding and the real
jeff galuli and he thought that it was
so fascinating that they both had wildly
differing accounts of what actually
happened
and so
that's sort of like a theme that's
threaded throughout
the movie is that you're not really
entirely sure what happened because
everybody's account of it was uh
was different in the sense that they
were just trying to make themselves look
good it wasn't just them though yeah
every news channel had a slightly
different take yeah every new story yeah
something different i mean there was
some
i believe that i for a while
uh up until this movie i thought tonya
harding hit that chick with the people i
don't know i never thought that although
i did see something i did see some
people that did think that but i never
thought that i knew it was somebody
that she had hired or that somebody that
jeff galloway had hired i didn't know
because it was a dude i remember them
saying that on the news or or leading
you to believe that and then this movie
this movie reminds you that some news
stories said that she did it
and as far as like i said i can't
remember i don't really remember um like
i remember when this happened but it was
like what like 1994 so it's like a long
time ago and you know i was like in my
early 20s it was a very long time ago
and um so i remember seeing because i
was kind of into you know i like to
watch figure skating and stuff so i did
kind of like follow this fairly closely
i don't remember any of the news things
saying outright that she had done it but
i'm not saying that that didn't happen
i'm just saying that that but they the
way they the way they worded it might
have suggested to some people because i
did see a couple people comment
on youtube videos that were reviewing
this movie that for a long time they
thought that she had actually done it
herself yeah that's what i thought but i
never i don't i never thought that i
just always knew it was a dude but they
the
the uh controversy arose over whether
she knew about the conspiracy because
there was a conspiracy whether she knew
about it ahead of time or whether she
only knew about it after the fact i was
led to believe that her and some dudes
did it
yeah that's that's you know which
that's kind of what happened
i believe this account in the movie it's
it's plausible i believe this count i i
think she didn't know
i i think she didn't know i mean the
thing about it i didn't know i was
curious because it had been a long time
since i thought about this case we
should probably do a show about this
because this is actually kind of
fascinating well it'd be like doing job
in a ramsey yeah you did that didn't we
have we done the job have we done john
bennett ramsay yet i thought we had
but
i know we were talking about it but then
we've done so many shows that i can't
remember i know we did like some other
high profile like child abductions like
metallica and what happened in that case
it's just that they couldn't say it on
the news the parents were defending some
of the person who really did it that's
what i think happened but the thing
about this movie though is that
it's told you know most of it is told
from tiny i mean they did like i said
it's based on real interviews with you
know mostly tommy tonya harding and jeff
galuli and some of the other actors that
were or other people that were involved
in it
so it's based on that even though it's
obviously actors playing them so
everybody has their own take on it now i
will say
and they go into this in the movie tanya
harding did get a plea deal
um you know with and they kind of get
into this at the end where they
basically like banned her from skating
like forever i don't even think she was
allowed to coach or anything like that
so which was like a big blow and they
kind of get into that in the end of the
movie which was actually kind of
heartbreaking really oddly uh saying
this is like a dark comedy
but
i was reading the wikipedia page because
i had forgotten a lot of the details of
this because i'm like well did she
actually how involved was she in this
because i can't really remember a lot of
the details now according to what
wikipedia said so i don't know if this
is true or not
but it said
that there had been an indictment
brought down
that they had found evidence that she
absolutely did know about it ahead of
time
but since she had already taken the plea
deal they just said well [ __ ] it she's
already been like punished okay from the
from like banning her
so i'm not really sure like what that
entailed
now if she for sure knew about it
afterward yeah which is you know that's
not legal either like what she should
have brought about death threats but not
necessarily known about the plot to
[ __ ] hit her in the knee with the
police baton
that's kind of well that's kind of how
the movie spit we'll see like i said the
movie's not i don't want to say the
movie spins it a particular way because
it doesn't the point of the movie
is that everybody involved that they
interviewed had a different story
and they're kind of showing all these
stories it even says like at a card at
the beginning this is all based on like
irony free
wildly contradictory interviews by like
all the people involved so you're kind
of led to
kind of come to your own conclusion
about it yeah but because so much of the
narrative is tonya harding's i guess
just by virtue of that it's going to be
more sympathetic to her point of view
it's just free on pluto tv no it's on
hulu it's on hulu
okay hulu tv that's where i saw it it
might be if it's free on hulu sometimes
it'll also be free on well no because
hulu you know who will you have to pay
wait to pay for that yeah who loses like
six bucks a month or eight years that
might be free on amazon too
mate i don't think it is though i didn't
see it was it well the reason that i
remembered about it was that i was
flipping through hulu the other day
looking for another movie and i was like
oh [ __ ] they have ice on you i've been
wanting to see that for a couple of
years it's worth watching it's so even
if you don't give a [ __ ] about figure
skating i really do usually even if you
don't like even if you don't even
remember when this happened it's it i
think it'll be a lot more resonant if
you actually did live through it because
like i said i remember this pretty
vividly because i was kind of into
figure skating at the time and i was
kind of watching it and um so but even
if you're not into that it is still
wildly entertaining yeah it's really
empty it is the tone is like pain and
gain it's very funny it's real funny
it's
but it's kind of tragic too i mean
she goes to hell she didn't have a good
upbringing
her mom was [ __ ] up her boyfriend was
[ __ ] up
she she was kind of like the least she's
she seems to be the most innocent person
out of them all she was really getting
the shitty of the stick i mean everyone
were kind of like idiots they were all
kind of and also kind of
shitty yeah everyone's kind of [ __ ] yeah
they're they're calling them rednecks
which redneck really doesn't fit she was
from up north all right well oregon
pacific northwest right that's still the
north you know the oregon yeah that's
about where uh yeah that's that's still
the north
yeah
but uh i would see more
more like a hillbilly
yeah more like a hillbilly in a way well
i kind of remember
when she first started kind of rising
through the ranks of figure skating back
in the 90s that was something that a lot
of people commented on because
she had homemade costumes and she figure
skated to like zz top and [ __ ] like that
which a lot of other skaters weren't
doing back then because everybody wanted
to be like pretty princess and
everything and she wasn't like that she
was a real kind of like like i said she
was a pretty girl but
she was
you know
kind of rough and tumble you know she
worked on cars she worked yeah [ __ ] like
that
and you know so she kind of like clawed
her way to the top
um
even though
i will say there was an element and i
remember this from the time too because
like i said i grew up in sort of a
redneck area so i kind of knew this
whole thing but the movie goes a little
bit into the kind of like classist
uh kind of [ __ ] that she got oh yeah
where whereas sometimes she would skate
better than the other girl or so or so
she believed but she skated really good
and they would still give her skater
yeah they they kind of gave her like low
scores because oh well you skated to
like some classic rock song or you had
kind of a shitty looking outfit or
something like that because she couldn't
afford the costumes and so a lot of
times she she made them herself and
stuff like that
and uh you know she looked kind of quote
unquote trashy if you wanna like i said
so they do kind of go into
that but like definitely she was a great
[ __ ] skater and honestly they and i'm
glad that they kind of go into this is
that she was
only the second female skater in the
world
uh to actually do a triple axel she had
those elevated testosterone levels maybe
for fighting her whole life yeah getting
punched in the face and the thing about
it said make her mad and she'll get she
skates better
i have to say that alice and janie's uh
oscar for this performance was well
earned yeah she is she pretty much
steals every scene that she's in she's
[ __ ] great at this she is just
smoking [ __ ] yeah she is just straight
up evil yeah um
but
i wanted to i read a little bit of an
interview with the actress because she
was saying well how i was approaching
this character was that
you know she was you know a stone cold
[ __ ] obviously but she was like
well-meaning she thought well i have to
like
make this kid tough because she's gonna
need to be tough like to get where she
wants to go
so
just from the time because i think the
movie it kind of like uh it kind of
starts in the present day and then it
goes back to when tanya is four like
when she first started out
and
just the way that her mom like talks to
her and treats and her mom is like kind
of like you know trashy and foul-mouthed
and [ __ ] like that is just constantly
chain smoking and [ __ ] and it's just
[ __ ] hilarious like it's hilarious
but it's also
[ __ ] up you know what i mean she comes
off like a russian female prison warrior
she does that yeah i was embarrassed for
you
you skinny like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
she told the [ __ ] people it would
suck my dick
[Laughter]
and she like she paid like at one
competition remember she paid a guy to
to to like heckle her
to tell her how much she sucked yeah to
make her skate better because he said
she's like we have to make her mad and
then that way she'll skate better yeah
oh my god yeah
that is just sounding elevated
testosterone [ __ ] levels [ __ ]
getting her to fight for survival
and i've seen her skate because they at
the end of the movies they they show hd
uh uh [ __ ] touch-ups yeah that
footage of her yeah and she isn't good
she isn't pretty she isn't good she was
a really good i mean she didn't get that
far for [ __ ] nothing you know what i
mean yeah and uh honestly i think
because of her background and the way
she was kind of yeah like i said she was
very rough and tumble she wasn't very
good at getting along with other people
because she wasn't really part of that
world yeah
so okay so she had to be better yeah
so they're asking in there if i'd seen
the porn uh yeah matter of fact we're
watching the movie [ __ ] he's like is
that still out there
it's real grainy and low-res from a vhs
tape and it's uh her and her
ex-husband's
wedding or or what is it uh not wedding
what do you call it uh honeymoon tape
and if i remember correctly and this
[ __ ] was on on from from howard stern
he's
the husband somehow had rights to sell
it i think he sold it
yeah i think well i think tanya had to
do with that she had to sign off on that
okay because i think it says on the
wikipedia page that they actually did
get like x amount i don't remember what
the amount was but yeah they they did
sell it it's not like it leaked or
anything like that they did actually
but that was one of the first celebrity
couples that made money doing that
and right after that the tommy lee and
pamela anderson tommy liam pamela was
before that but i was i might be
remembering it wrong like i said it was
like it was a big rash of that [ __ ] even
paris hilton [ __ ] her take how did
that get out and pretend
they would pretend that it was leaking
no they were [ __ ] selling it [ __ ] of
course and just yeah
but they were hurting for money so they
released it and um
i remember guys reading it and but they
were renting it mostly just like a curio
i mean it it's not [ __ ] it's not any
good at all
you can't barely see anything and it's
just you know well i kind of feel like a
lot of those celebrity sex tapes they're
like well we're celebrities it's not
like we have to have like really high
production values or anything like that
people will pay to see it just because
it's a famous person yeah there's really
nice matter how crappy it looks and in
some ways if the crappier it looks the
more likely that people are to like get
all off on it because they think oh that
that's it's more likely to be authentic
or whatever you're seeing them like a
real person the only good one from that
era was pamela anderson and [ __ ]
tommy
that was like that was like some good
[ __ ] well that was kind of like the
gold standard that's the girls standard
they're they're on celebrity league yeah
look at tommy's [ __ ] on the yacht
[ __ ] the pilot in the yacht getting
blown and [ __ ]
pamela's looking gorgeous you know if i
can run around
and it was you know just it was like
gonzo porn
yeah i think they recorded it with a
full intensive release of course fully
yeah they were stunned because they
needed i think they were starting to
need money in their career and
that must have made a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton
of money
now i'm kind of curious i'm sure there's
a wikipedia page about that too you
probably look it up and say how much
money did this you know you can answer
everything now it happened in a time
where it was different when it was
difficult to control the medium
i mean you had vh vcr or vhs to vhs
recording but it was a pain in the ass
it was easier just to buy the 40 tape
you know the 30 tape whatever
and you know
they didn't really have
they had some cable services for porn
and the internet really wasn't strong
yet so that was how
that made a lot of money
paris hilton did too
yeah that's kind of like the last big
one that i remember yeah it's not like i
keep she was cute but she was flat and i
don't like that just a girl
you were just like man yeah yeah and it
was done in night shot
[ __ ] low light night shot
so she was like plausible deniability
like that's not me that's you
yeah uh but yeah so yeah we did like and
honestly
this is kind of hard to say because i
don't really like i said i wasn't there
i don't know
and this movie doesn't take a stand on
whether because nobody knows
over whether tanya harding knew about
the attack on nancy kerrigan before it
happened she for sure knew about it
after it happened but
the way that it's portrayed in the film
jeff galuli said
that who was her husband at the time
they're kind of on again off again
he said that originally what they were
going to do was that they were going to
engage in what he called psychological
warfare by sending death threats to
nancy kerrigan to like throw her off her
game so she would [ __ ] up and so you
know tonya harding would win
um he got this idea because someone had
sent a death threat to tanya harding and
then later you find out that it's
actually a friend of jeff gulley who did
that and blah blah blah
so
initially so how the movie portrays it
is that jeff insists
that
tanya just thought he's like she knew
that we were gonna do something to nancy
harrigan but she thought that it was
just gonna be like death threats like we
were just gonna mail death threats to
her to throw her off her game or
whatever um but
he insists that unbeknownst to her he
paid a thousand dollars
to
this chubby friend of his who said he
was an expert in
international counter terrorism was that
what he said yeah that character is
amazing and honestly it's like you watch
this movie and you think that that
character is like that can't possibly be
real but then they show
clips of like the real guy like during
the credits and stuff like that you're
like oh my god it absolutely it's real
yeah it's
he was like talking about he was a spy
and he'd been like all over the [ __ ]
world like doing this and that like
[ __ ] brother yeah
he made steven seagal look credible
he made
and he was just like completely
the funniest thing about it was that he
was completely um naive to how like dumb
he was
and he thought that everybody like
actually believed this shtick about and
actually it's funny because i guess
um you know jeff galuli and the other
guy that actually did the
the kneecapping
they actually kind of believed it too
but everybody involved in this like jeff
galuli was an idiot um and the two
friends that he worked with
to do the kneecapping also idiots but
they weren't aware that they were idiots
which is where a lot of the humor in
this movie comes from they think that
they're these like international [ __ ]
not i guess not so much as in pain and
gain because those guys were also idiots
that thought they were like master
criminals it's kind of the same sort of
vibe here it's painted they [ __ ] but
they make like really really stupid
mistakes like they even say like in this
movie and i tonya like the one guy it's
like they they called like to find out
where nancy kerrigan trains because
that's where they're gonna do it
and
they not only do they go to the wrong
place like in the wrong [ __ ] city
but then the guy says oh well to keep
from drawing suspicion to myself i'm
going to park in this one spot for 15
minutes and then move to another spot
for another 15 minutes and then another
spot for 15. and he did that for like
two solid days and he wasn't even at the
right place and like the cameras like
caught him doing it yeah and they're
like what the [ __ ] that is like really
suspicious what is going on there so
they just did all this like really
stupid [ __ ] that pain again the guys
were so dumb that they were almost
geniuses
when they
these are muscle men dressed up as
ninjas with ninja weapons
yeah and when people saw it
and reported it to the police the police
said that that [ __ ] was so dumb they
didn't believe it
they're like yeah
see so maybe in some ways there might be
some merit to just doing something so
stupid and ridiculous
that no one would believe that anyone
would actually be so stupid
that's not what it was though they
thought in order to commit the crime you
better [ __ ] dress up like ninjas
because it's like tactical
nobody will see us
that's what they were thinking
will look professional
yeah they they genuinely did seem to
think that yeah which like i said that's
where the hilarity comes from because
obviously i mean even though that's you
know a tragic case like people got
murdered right that's like not funny
when they ran up on when they invaded
dudes florida home they were all wearing
tiger stripe [ __ ] camouflage like
they were in vietnam and [ __ ]
i cannot imagine being that clueless i
just can't and of course i know some
people are we're talking about some of
them talking about a florida
basically a florida area like this like
it's almost kind of like excerpts
you know it's excerpts
or suburbs
outside the suburbs that would be
excerpts right
yeah although like i said he's in the
rich neighborhood yeah he deserves yeah
so they're gonna wear [ __ ] camouflage
and no one will see him of course yeah
no that won't stick out
yeah
not at all yeah heaven forbid we dress
up like the domino's pizza man
somebody might see us
yeah it's like why didn't they dress up
like [ __ ]
you know the spy movies will [ __ ] and
[ __ ] show you man you dress up as the
ups man
yeah or like the amazon prime
is there somebody who belongs [ __ ]
nobody would give that person a second
look because they're supposed to be
there nope some of the real pros in
these [ __ ] war-torn areas they just
[ __ ] assemble a [ __ ] police
uniform and do that because
if you see cops [ __ ] shooting the
place up what do you do you gonna call
the cops no you're gonna go run
oh [ __ ] there's a batch of coffee guys
are happening sure bad guys
yeah yeah yeah because
the cops are killing bad guys
you know yeah that's not what it is
though
tyler says i think pain and gain was a
little more fictionalized than this one
was yeah i will give it that yeah um but
that's what made that one awesome though
but yeah i mean this one was really not
all that fictionalized at least
according to
um
tanya's account and jeff golubley's
account i will say
as much of an idiot as jeff goluli is
um that when they did the interviews for
this movie
he they offered him money and he
wouldn't take it
okay um so and they actually kind of
like went into at the end of this movie
because the end of this movie was
actually like kind of touching yeah they
there's this scene at the end where you
know tonya harding has to you know they
do the plea deal and the judge is giving
her the sentence and she got like what
it was like some like suspended sentence
or 15 months yeah something like that 18
months suspended yeah 18 months to spend
it that's what she didn't spend any time
in jail but they said well you're banned
from skating like you can't be and you
can't do it and she just like
she flipped out she like started like
crying and she's like that's all he she
knows how to do she wanted to go to jail
do the jail she would have rather done
the jail time she said i'll do the jail
time i just you can't do this to me this
is all i know how to do and it was like
really sad because that's the thing it's
like that is all that she knew how to do
she became a boxer her entire life yeah
like she didn't she wasn't good at
school she didn't go to college nothing
like that but she like she was an
amazing [ __ ] figure skater yeah and
she was so good at that and then whether
she knew about the plot you know to
kneecap nancy kerrigan ahead of time i
don't know if she didn't know
then that is like the worst [ __ ] ever
because jeff galuli he says that she
didn't know
and that he feels the reason he won't
take any money for anything is because
he feels really bad just like he says in
this movie um that he ruined her life he
ruined her career i don't think she knew
about the kneecap
i think she knew about
them calling her and harassing her
because people harassed her
yeah i think yeah i think she gave the
she gave the okay to that i think yeah
we're going to do some psychological
warfare yeah which that's not cool
either
but
that's it's a very far cry she didn't
have to do anything she was good enough
to compete with that all that [ __ ] but
maybe she didn't feel like that because
the thing about it that they kind of go
into i don't want to say that this
this movie's not like
overly sympathetic to tanya you know it
doesn't romanticize her
but it does kind of show like why she
ended up the way she ended up and if her
mom was really like that they do have a
clip of like her actual mom like toward
the end if her mom was really like that
then
it's kind of amazing that she actually
turned out as relatively normal as it
did and i know that's that's again a
relative term
but
because having a mom like that that was
constantly
you know and the mom maybe had some
other
she wouldn't even like say she loved her
she wouldn't do anything like that like
the one time that she comes to her house
like later on after the whole debacle
happens
and she pretends it's like oh i'm sorry
i'm so proud of you and then hugs her
and then it turns out that she's wearing
a wire
like to get her to like confess and
she's going to sell it to the press so
her mom clearly
you know at least in the movie at least
according to tanya's perception does not
really give a [ __ ] about her and it's
like whether the mom actually thought
well i have to be tough on you to make
you a champion i mean it did work
but
having that relentlessly drilled into
you from the time you're four years old
that's not going to be good for your
mental health you're never going to feel
like you're good enough so i kind of
feel like maybe you know i'm not
excusing it i'm just saying if she did
know about the kneecapping ahead of time
she would have said well that you know
there
there's so many uh unfair other people
have unfair advantages over me so i'm
gonna like you know have an unfair
advantage over them for a change tyler
has uh as far because they're talking
about pain and gain in there
again um no need for me saying how good
mark wahlberg and [ __ ] the rock were in
pain and gain how they made that movie
work
yeah okay pain and gain might have been
a little bit fictionalized but not so
much the subject matter or anything i
mean what happened that is what happened
yeah that's pretty much what happened
right what was fictionalized was the
tone
the tone and the over the over-the-top
kind of delivery of the material
uh to make it a little bit more exciting
and funnier and weirder you know they
were weird
uh so i think the tone was slightly
fictionalized they're torturing the dude
that's not funny you know what i mean
but [ __ ] you know that couldn't be
funny but it kind of made it a little
bit funny yeah
so i think they just kind of
fictionalized the tone of it and
probably the settings they made the
settings look pretty glamorous and high
uh high-end
i got a feeling you know the uh the the
gym where he worked wasn't as high-end
as they showed it i got a feeling that a
lot of the uh a lot of the new yorkers
that they were [ __ ] over there that
their houses weren't that nice they were
probably like the like ours but they
were showing like the
millionaire matches i doubt it i doubt
that but see that's what i'm saying
about
dark comedy is really hard to pull off
well yeah people did it pain and gain
did it and this movie absolutely did it
so i can see like watching this movie
i [ __ ] loved this movie seriously
like i said even if you don't care about
figure skating you don't care about that
this is still like super super
entertaining and you should watch it but
it's like
and again like pain and gain you know so
people got tortured and murdered and
it's not funny that's not funny yeah and
like in this one you know there's
domestic abuse there's not only um you
know tonya's mom beating up on her but
also jeff gillooly beating up on her
she's punching her just [ __ ] punching
her and [ __ ] like that and it's [ __ ]
up yeah um and to make that funny and to
make it like a dark comedy that's really
really
yeah hard that's like that's like a
[ __ ] tight rope kind of [ __ ] but they
absolutely did it she didn't take that
[ __ ] lying down either she grabbed that
[ __ ] shotgun was shooting at him and
stuff although she said i didn't do this
while she's like
she was a fighter
she fought back
yeah
she did kind of go into and like i said
a lot of um children that went through
abuse have the same kind of thing you
get uh the thing where you feel like you
deserve it
um so that's why a lot of people uh
particularly women that grow up uh you
know abused by their parents and they
will go up and grow up and uh get into
relationships with people that abuse
them because they think that that's
that that's how people show love that's
how they show that they care about you
by beating the crap out of you
and they think that they deserve it and
she kind of goes into that a little bit
so there is like a lot of that there's a
lot of like deeper issues in this like
about her
but
it
it's it's really like hard to
it's really hard to explain because it's
like it's not played for laughs it's not
making fun of her no
um making fun of the situation it's kind
of making fun of the situation because
the situation was absurd yeah the whole
everybody in this [ __ ] is absurd yeah
the whole debacle
about it was it was absurd it was an
absurd situation tanya is the least
absurd at all of them pretty much anyone
[ __ ] taking all the heat and it's
kind of and like i said if you see it
like that
um you know if indeed she didn't know
about the
the actual physical attack then this is
almost like plays like a tragedy like
it's funny but it almost plays like a
tragedy because her whole entire career
was ruined like i said and she became
and she even says this in the movie she
became you know a punchline yeah and she
did and i remember that happening there
was like they even had like in the
background of one of the scenes they had
like david letterman doing his top 10
and it was all about her like making fun
of her
and
you know for a long time after this
happened she just became a [ __ ] joke
yeah and
like you said after a while she was
banned from skating she couldn't skate
anymore so you know and she didn't have
any money it's because i kind of feel
like people feel like oh well that
you're in the olympics so you got money
then you got money but no um you know if
you don't win if you don't come in like
you know the first the top one you don't
get anything because all those athletes
have is usually like you know
endorsements like company endorsements
and stuff and if you don't come in like
the top on the top then no one's going
to give a [ __ ] so you just got to go
back she'd had to go back to her like
[ __ ] job at spud city or whatever it
was she was like a waitress and she had
to go back to that and like couldn't
afford anything and after she was banned
from skating um she basically had to do
[ __ ] like sell sex tapes or yeah she
went on like celebrity boxing type of
[ __ ] i think she was on um
she was on some reality show with
[ __ ] kato kaelin remember him
the guy that lived behind the o.j
simpson gk like i think it was called
like the five minutes of her 15 minutes
of fame edition of whatever show it was
and she was on there with kato kalyn uh
might have been celebrity death match or
one of those like celebrity boxing kind
of things so she was on there with that
and i don't know like she got married
later on to somebody else and like had a
kid and she's apparently like doing okay
nowadays but she does now she just does
like um like construct like house
construction and
[ __ ] like painting and [ __ ] like that
working yeah she has like a construct
like a kind of a construction business
as far as i could determine
so
it's honestly if you think about it it's
actually really kind of sad
like i said if she didn't know about it
then this is probably she's got her just
desserts but had she made it through the
olympics and even won at this time in
her life really the best she best thing
she could be would be a trainer
yeah
which probably was what she would have
wanted because you think that's what a
lot of because she seemed like the kind
of person that
this was all she ever wanted she was
very very driven and this was all she
knew how to do and she was really good
at it and she loved it it makes you
wonder why she couldn't be a trainer
just as she is the way she is
she can't compete but does that mean she
can't train
um i guess well you couldn't do anything
i think one of the um stipulations of
the plea deal was that she couldn't have
anything to do with like the official
body official body right um
but she could probably open up i don't
know maybe she doesn't want to like
expose herself to that anymore because i
feel like although
i don't know maybe everybody would have
forgotten about it for a little while
they would have forgotten about it this
movie ended about
everybody was reminded you know what's
hilarious i was reading the wikipedia
page about this margot robbie
who you know obviously plays tanya
harding and she was also the co-producer
on this
she when she first read the screenplay
she uh didn't realize this if this was
based on a true story oh he did she
didn't
it's like i was like is she really that
much younger than us i guess she must be
yeah she wasn't old enough she wasn't
old enough to like remember it yeah and
it's like it's funny because i when we
got to the part in the movie
where because i remember very much
after the whole they call it the
incident in the movie like where she
knee captain uh
somebody else or somebody kneecapped her
like i don't know if she had anything to
do with it or not but um when nancy
kerrigan got kneecaps and then i
remember like the [ __ ] i guess it was
the olympus lillahammer right
and it was 94.
and
the media were like having a [ __ ]
field day because this was the first
time like nancy kerrigan had healed and
this was the first time she was going to
be competing i think like since then and
she was going to be competing against
tonya harding
you know with a bunch of other i think
uh was it oksana bayul and uh
katarinavit there was like a bunch of
other skaters there as well
and so the media we're selling is this
big oh it's like uh the [ __ ] showdown
you know what i mean between [ __ ] uh
tonya harding and nancy kerrigan's the
first time they're meeting on the ice
since the incident and all this others
and i remember like the [ __ ] hype
about it back in 1994
and when we were watching the movie i
was like oh i remember that they hyped
the [ __ ] out of this like they were
playing it like it was this [ __ ] big
[ __ ] death match and then when they
skated nancy kerrigan got the silver so
she came in second
and uh tonya harding came in eighth
so it was like
it was like some big wet fart and uh
it's really funny because in the movie
uh margot robbie as tonya harding she
says and i remember this too and that's
why i laughed when i saw this scene
she's like if you watch the footage of
nancy kerrigan with her silver medal
like on the thing it's like she looks
like she smells a poo yeah
and i was like yeah that's exactly what
her face looked like yeah she was just
kind of like my face i should have won
i'm not [ __ ] on nancy kerrigan i'm
sure she's a lovely person and honestly
um it's funny because i guess nancy
kerrigan got asked about this movie like
when it came out and nancy was just
basically kind of like whatever she's
like
i got my own life she's like she was an
amazing skater and she was very classy
about it um you know she's like i'm not
gonna be probably not gonna watch the
movie but you know what i mean why would
you
but she's like that was a long time ago
and she's got her family i got my family
and nobody's really worried about it
anymore you know so i didn't know it was
margot robbie yeah man so in the very
beginning that it was her
yeah and and you you don't you don't
recognize her
well yeah because eventually you kind of
do but not at first the kid that the
little girl that plays her like when
she's a kid i'm pretty sure that's the
same kid
that was in goddammit what the [ __ ] was
she in i feel like she was in
the black coat's daughter like when she
or something like that i think that's
that same action the [ __ ] is that
actress's name when she was like a
little little kid but once um tonya
harding gets to like 15 16 then margot
robbie please her yeah you don't
recognize it as margot robbie it looks
because they did they did that horrible
like 80s hair yeah and braces and the
braces and like bad clothes yeah
[ __ ] up makeup that they wore oh my
god and it wasn't everybody wearing that
makeup but that was just the standard
you know that was all makeup that was
kind of like your standard trailer park
and like i said i'm not [ __ ] because
i grew up in a trailer park today so you
know what i mean i'm not being
judgmental it's just
the time that's what was in style for
them yeah and you know and uh this movie
too
has a [ __ ] ton of classic rock favorites
yeah in it
um well this easy top song sleeping bag
they put that in there well she actually
did skate to that i remember seeing that
actually
um
and it ends with susie though it does
and she never p she never skated to that
yeah but the director of the film was
like i just always thought there would
be something really cool about
having footage of the real tanya harding
skating to susie the banshee's cover of
the passenger and so that's over the end
credits oh i have to say too that margot
robbie
did a lot of her own skating for this
she trained for many months
and actually wounded herself many times
while she was working on it obviously um
they couldn't find anybody that could do
a triple axel because a lot of skaters
female ones especially and male ones too
like uh can't do it so they actually had
to do that with cgi but the cgi in this
is like so seamless that
i never noticed because i'm looking i
was like where okay let me see where the
stunt double is because i know that she
didn't but honestly margot robbie did do
a lot of rune skating and um but like i
said the triple axel they had to do that
with cgi because nobody can do it really
there's only like a couple skaters in
the world that can actually do it and
they actually kind of like explain it in
the movie
but um
i will uh this movie did actually get
that [ __ ] super [ __ ] song stuck in
my head though i've had that [ __ ]
goodbye stranger that super [ __ ] song
has been stuck in my head all day long
since we watched it last night but uh
yeah um
yes knitting for me too so it's easy top
cheap sunglasses yeah um
i didn't even realize margot was playing
her now i'll definitely check it out is
she making anything from it i came late
so i missed some in the beginning and
this movie came out back in 2017. i
didn't realize it was that old already
i remember hearing about it and i was
like oh i gotta see that because i
remember when that when all that [ __ ]
happened but then i kind of forgot about
it but then when i was scrolling through
hulu last night i was like oh yeah we
wanted and tom's like did we want to see
that and i was like yeah let's watch
that and i was like it's funny because
all the matinees we've done this week we
did the devils
we did
mommy dearest and we did this one and i
said oh and they're all like crazy
movies that are based on true stories
and we didn't even mean to do that
that was a total accident and um
and this one actually is kind of like
mommy dearest in the sense that the
mother-daughter relationship in this is
super super [ __ ] up and abusive so
there's that too we had a whole theme
going you know we didn't even mean to
have a whole theme going uh but yeah so
if you have hulu i'm sure you can get
this on other streaming services but you
have hulu uh this is on there and as i
said pretty much every review of this
movie i've seen has been wildly positive
it was nominated for all the [ __ ]
awards and it won a few and it's very
easy to see why like i said even if you
don't give a [ __ ] about figure skating
or any of that um this is still like
super super entertaining super super
funny like i said if you especially if
you like dark comedies that have kind of
like
that it kind of has like a heart to it
too you know what i mean because like i
said it's almost like a tragedy but not
overtly you know what i mean um but yeah
like i really really like the tone of it
yeah if you like pain and gain you
probably like this because the tone of
it is kind of similar although
pain and gain i guess was kind of darker
because people got murdered um this one
somebody just got
their leg broken which is bad but not
obviously as bad as being headaches
darker and funnier
i don't know well yeah it's funnier yeah
uh this one's pretty [ __ ] funny this
is funny too it's just it's different
it's there but it's similar yeah if you
like the penny game you'd like this yeah
and like i said especially if you're
into like watching like 80s and 90s
[ __ ] fashions and classic rock and
all that kind of stuff it's like this
was super fun i had a really good time
with it but uh yeah so that'll do it for
this matinee now tomorrow night is our
regular show
and we are doing another thing a little
bit akin to our phantom of the opera one
and we're doing
the real stories behind some
fairy tales like grimm's fairy tales
that were based on like some kind of
real [ __ ]
yeah uh that was the topic that
overwhelmingly won and i'm kind of
excited about it because that sounds
like a fun topic anyway um so yeah we
will see you guys tomorrow night for our
main show
so
thanks for dropping by and we'll see you
tomorrow bye